joining me now is harriet hageman the
wyoming congressional candidate who just
defeated liz cheney
harriet first of all congratulations i
remember talking to you before you
decided uh you were going to throw your
hat in the ring for real uh and now you
know you got it girl you're the uh
you're the gonna be the nominee for the
party and uh i can't imagine you won't
be the next uh congresswoman from the
great state of wyoming
well thank you laura it's wonderful to
be back with you we started this a year
ago or about 11 months ago and here we
are with all of the hard work and the
support of the great people across the
state of wyoming and all of our
volunteers and supporters we've been
able to succeed
did liz cheney call you and congratulate
you how was the tone of that
conversation
i haven't had an opportunity to visit
with her we have been kind of wrapped up
in in all of the stuff associated with
what's going on downstairs with our
watch party as you can imagine we have
several hundred people downstairs ready
to celebrate who've been celebrating and
so i have not been able to uh even look
at my phone so i don't know if she's
called or not
so i don't really have anything to
report on that
oh that's interesting did you happen to
hear that
part of her speech was a continued vow
harriet
to make sure donald trump never
steps foot in the white house after what
happened on january 6
which was
not
i guess not surprising that she said
that but your reaction tonight
well again i have not had a child an
opportunity to even see or hear what she
had to say because i've been kind of
focused on what's going on here it
doesn't surprise me that she would
revert to those same old talking points
because that's really in large part what
got her defeated she's not focusing on
wyoming she's not focusing on our issues
she's still focusing on an obsession
about president trump and the citizens
of wyoming the voters of wyoming sent a
very loud message tonight we have spoken
and that is not what we are interested
in in terms of our lone congressional
representative wyoming is entitled to
have a representative that represents
our interests that listens to us that
addresses our issues that isn't liz
cheney and the fact that that's where
she went back to with her speech tonight
i think demonstrates that she really
isn't listening to wyoming now she
hasn't for quite some time and that's
why we needed to replace her we need to
have a representative in wyoming who
listens to us
and harriet when i was lucky enough to
spend quite a bit of time in wyoming in
july the things that i heard
most often from folks there were
inability to get workers
the cost of fuel
and the cost of just basic living rent
and food
no one was focusing on trump that i i
don't think anyone i talked to that
wasn't
top of mind
no inflation illegal immigration and
protection of our energy jobs are the
issues that are the most important to
wyoming and accountability we actually
expect our representatives to represent
our interests i've said that a couple of
times now but that's what i heard so
much on the campaign trail so i'm
excited thank you for having us it's a
it's a wonderful evening
harriet congratulations we can't wait to
see what the future holds for you you
worked hard this campaign we really
appreciate it hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else